how's it going everybody there's been a
lot of talk and a lot of speculation
recently about the title of Avengers for
the Russo brothers have once stated that
the title won't be revealed for a while
but we now have the Captain Marvel
trailer and Captain Marvel comes out not
too long before Avengers 4 so the
trailer for Avengers 4 is probably not
too far away so the title should be
actually coming pretty soon and one fan
thinks they figured it out and it makes
a lot of sense real quick if you'd like
to enter my giveaway for your chance to
win a copy of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray some special edition posters and
some special memorabilia all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
reddit user tmk tanner has recently
shared his ideas and thoughts about what
he thinks the Avengers for title will be
now although his title has been said
before it does seem to make the most
sense out of all the titles that are out
there right now so Infinity Ward dealt
with all corners of space infinite space
that never ends and the Russo brothers
have said that the title does have
something to do with forever just as
space goes on forever it's infinite and
with Avengers 4 we've seen a lot of
evidence that leads us to believe that
time travel will be involved in the
quantum realm will be involved what all
of this really points to is the title
eternity war eternity represents all of
time so it goes right along with
infinity and again one fan suggested
Avengers forever as the title and the
rooster brother said that forever wasn't
too far off and fans are getting close
not to mention Avengers eternity war
would set up the Eternals pretty nicely
and we all know in phase four we're
getting a movie about the Eternals so
out of all the titles that have been
suggested out there this one seems to
make the most sense but what do you all
think could Avengers Eternity war
possibly be the title is this it has it
been discovered let me know what you
think in the comments below don't forget
to subscribe like and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so you can enter the giveaway
and as always thank you so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]